hello and welcome to this video Wow bad
days he has a enormously high rating Wow
to how do you get there to 480 tier 2
550 Wow a place that with symbols and
quite successfully word I never knew
that he's that strong in blitz chess now
when you play the same yields you always
get this kind of standard rating on
display not the five-minute and so I
didn't know that he is such a strong
player he has a name in now Duncan
Malone northampton massachusetts ellis
guy but he's probably untitled and with
its raining Wow
I mean close to 2,500 in the five-minute
pool is usually just reached by grand
masters or yeah good I a mess in regards
to blitz no that's the main line of them
usually they play the Queen back to a
five-man they're probably it's no
particular reason there
9h 5 pool ok now I'm absolutely out of
book hmmm now wipe this often play h3
maybe that's the reason why why why
players um go for that you ask me this
game will be on the channel layer of it
will be yeah I guess it will so what
about this and there he says hello
YouTube ok and can I do something
technical here ouch Bishop g5 h sigma xi
x 4g 595 htx my it's completely
ridiculous oh ok let's a centralized but
that cannot be the right way to play
this with white
now just a bad opening result
thank you will take or play Bishop g4
maybe but I would just take care with
black netting okay it's a good move
definitely this is all circles yeah 94
is the problem this is now part of this
equation 1095 looks wrong yeah that also
looks wrong I hate my position and
really isn't good as a super lame yeah
so I have to go f3m 22 was wrong at all
it also feels like i had this get this
on the board of the bird on the board in
some earlier game
and it takes a long time I have two wins
against and from the live session last
one day and in this live session he had
some time problems okay a bishop f7
takes Quincy focus should be six I don't
have 95 unfortunately
this is the wrong radiance bishops III
mmm too I need to get some activity here
otherwise I'm just worse
yeah just we should be six what sorts
the deal
very long time spent for that for school
so what now beyond ig5 it's not a big
threat and I have 22 double points of g3
and b3
very unattractive position for white
he's taking me to see him jack okay
Brooke chicks now I can I came out plain
night takes that that's ridiculous he
might win this poor now but that that's
just what it is i have to have to live
with that or die with it whatever need
to go for some some kind of activity him
Queen g7 or age five maybe h5 we Nev 637
no he just grabs everything of course ok
friends would be seven it's not getting
any quicker here
so Ruby seven you're saying that this is
not a made right with 727 Queen f7 King
h6 chicken there is no made time morning
great um
okay now i can take right now sorry i
have to win this on time I mean this is
absolutely it's taking so long for his
moves f8 ok yeah but now I I can go for
this I'm active enough like that's our
time they played in a strong way it was
just immensely slow yeah ok so probably
Queenie to is wrong and I probably have
to do this here right I think this is
the way of playing this this and then
after this you can can go here I give a
couple of options you know yeah I keep
forgetting the theory h3 is a lot better
at night h5 is indeed awkward it's
really awkward yeah i'm just doing him
yeah and she was it was correctly played
in even the porn grab is ok h5 and I
just blind the test I didn't see that it
was hanging but this is a cool movie I
was thinking that this is a threat but
you can actually take it and just go
here and black wins so I had to continue
with the move like this and now we gauge
maybe seven by now i mean Amber's but it
seems to you know it seems to be okay
actually I get stuff back but this was I
mostly decided by his son his time
management is spent far too much far too
much time ok thanks for watching